okay guys don't think I get sustained
today I am so excited because I'm
unboxing for you the new Nintendo 2ds XL
and this was announced a while ago and a
lot of you guys but like Justine or
you're gonna get it tell us we need to
know her name my channel you probably
don't know that I was beyond obsessed
with my 3ds
I think everywhere I can forget my
wallet at home but I would not forget my
3ds Street passes for my life now it's
infinite and a switch came out and it
doesn't have StreetPass I'm not as
inclined to take it everywhere and
there's two new games that are coming
out me topia and hey Pikmin don't get me
wrong I do wish there was on the switch
so that I could carry around one device
and one device to rule them all but
clearly by the launch of this new
handheld device it's very obvious that
in Tendo is still in the market for
these so what I'm curious as to what is
that distinction between who would buy a
switch and who would buy a 2ds be
interested to see what you guys think
about that in the comments below but in
the meantime let's open this up and
let's take a look I was so excited about
the Pikmin 2 me though I may or may not
do a little bit of gameplay for you but
I don't know how to capture from a 3d s
2d s I never even played in 3d does
anybody actually ever really play in 3d
on their 3ds stop talking open up
I'm shocked they have a charger with it
that was like the biggest dilemma in the
past three DS's you have to buy the
charger separate and you even I can't I
like the blue a lot too
this looks so good got our charging port
back here our stylist headphone jack
that's a real big slot I always sit the
digital downloads and I'm so used to
seeing the tiny tiny little cards for
the entender switch toaster size
comparison between 3ds this is probably
my favorite version other than the
galaxy 3dsxl this is the GameStop NES
exclusive my mom bought me this for
Christmas I believe I was so excited
about it it's really not that much
smaller to be honest with you the 3ds XL
is a little bit taller you should have
been a ball or a shot-caller
[Music]
then you open it up it has a much
smoother feel this has like the click so
that's for like a screen size comparison
the screen looks almost the same size
it's basically the 2d s fits quite
nicely hidden to the 3d is let's take a
little peek in comparison to than
antennas which look at you you look good
got an antenna switch and we've got our
2d s but you basically fits quite nicely
there in the middle of the screen
what is so intriguing to me is I really
forgot how big these cards were I mean
in comparison to the switch cartridges
you know what's something I never did is
I never did taste the cartridge I don't
want to do it I don't want to do it I'm
scared
should I like what's the bad side
[Music]
Oh God oh my god how did I not do that
until now how have I not tasted the
Nintendo switch cartridge for the five
months that this thing is been oh my god
it tastes like a freaking it tastes so
disgusting I really should have just
trusted the internet think clay to get a
good look of it and I've been drinking
this oh my god it's the taste is still
in my freaking tongue I'm such an idiot
what's this stupid I would told myself I
was not gonna taste the freaking
cartridge Never Say Never
who said that Justin Bieber let's take a
peek at these little amiibo oh no so but
just beautiful plastic there is so much
detail in this then look at the grass
[Music]
so that's that the detent switch
cartridge does in fact taste disgusting
the 2d s XL is much smaller than the 3ds
XL but not by that much I'll see you
guys later thanks for watching
[Music]